foreign
[Music]
Dr Alika LaFontaine is an
anesthesiologist with 20 years
experience in medicine but for the next
year he's got a new job
president of the Canadian Medical
Association the largest national
advocacy group for doctors
on a recent trip to BC Dr lafontaine's
colleagues at Royal Columbian Hospital
in New Westminster made him feel right
at home in the operating room
a far cry from his days in medical
school a time he says was so difficult
he almost walked away from his dream it
was very intimidating for me coming into
medical school without having any
medical background on either side of my
family my mom's a first generation
immigrant my dad comes from a small
farming community in Saskatchewan so
ever since we were young we didn't have
a lot but we we always had Big Dreams I
sit here now as the head of an
association that's been around for more
than 155 years you know there's more
than 92 000 Physicians across this
country
and we all share a belief that we can
make a difference in people's lives I
think the the scariest part of what's
going on right now when it comes to
Physicians and providers is that
they've lost hope
would you say Canada's Health Care
system is collapsing
I would absolutely say that it's
collapsing and for a lot of us
we hear about this collapse but it
doesn't affect us directly
and
when you actually are in the health
system where people are waiting you know
10 20 hours to get into an emergency
room or when someone puts an
advertisement into a newspaper hoping
that they can connect with a family doc
you can't help but acknowledge that we
are at a very very different place than
we've ever been in healthcare
why is Canada's Health Care System
collapsing the crisis was decades in the
making right I think we often look to
covet as you know the triggering event
but in reality whether it was covet or
something else there was a stress that
was coming on the system these decisions
we've made over the years weaken the
link between patients and providers and
I think if we rethink the way that we
design care around that again I think we
have a lot of Hope of making our way
through this stress
many Canadians are experiencing that
stress through a lack of access to
doctors long waits for treatment and
Hospital closures
but doctors and nurses say their mental
health is worse now than ever more than
half of Health Care Professionals are
experiencing severe burnout
when you hear from people that you know
they're either scaling back the amount
of clinical time that they're going to
do whether you're a physician or a nurse
or other Allied Health provider or
they're thinking of leading medicine
entirely because of the stresses and
burden of what they're experiencing day
to day you know that the need for that
isn't just urgent it's
it's something that you have to do right
now one of the most amazing things for
me to witness was how a generation of
Canadians became armchair
epidemiologists and if we can include
Canadians in this conversation where
they start to understand health
care in a way that they didn't before
I I think we'll move that conversation
in the direction it needs to go how do
you think that approach could help
there's two things that I think can help
immediately you know the the first is
breaking down those silos that we have
eventually so we can actually start to
share information people and resources
in a much more collaborative and
coordinated way the second part is
making sure that we move towards true
team-based care and so Physicians have a
role nurses have a role you know
Pharmacists and other members of the
healthcare team have a role and it's
respecting that we're all trained
differently we all do different things
well I want to ask you question in the
context of that 2020 report called in
plain sight that talked about systemic
racism in BC's Health Care System but
experts have said you could essentially
apply the findings of that to every
Province and territory how do you begin
to tackle such an ingrained issue like
that one of the insights that I've had
over the past 20 years is that
racialization isn't about the person
sitting across from news about yourself
it's about how you see the people that
come into
the places that you provide care and
what you're willing to accept as far as
lived experience and evidence you know
the experience of racism is real I've
experienced it myself I have family
members who've experienced it
organizations like the Canadian Medical
Association that have been around for
155 years
you know they're on their own path
towards reconciliation
and there's a lot of positive things
happening right now you know we've never
had more indigenous physicians in this
country than we've had now and once we
can acknowledge that things are real we
can then work towards those solutions
that I think are are in the hands of the
people that experience them undoubtedly
as the first indigenous president of the
Canadian Medical Association you are a
role model does that come with added
pressure I've had the opportunity to
stand on the shoulders of a lot of
amazing people
and I have to be ready to have people
stand on my shoulders you know I I'm not
going to be able to solve these problems
by myself
and if you look at leadership as a
process where it's not about your voice
but amplifying the voices of people who
are actually creating change
that weight doesn't feel as heavy
[Music]
to a group is something Dr LaFontaine
has experience with and you may have
even heard it before
he grew up singing and playing music
with his siblings
performing in front of Canadian
audiences as the fifth generation a
touring band
and that family bond is important to him
I have amazing wife as well as four
amazing children you know my kids were
so excited when they found out that I
had been selected by Alberta Physicians
to become this year's CMA president
medicine
is a type of job where you give a lot
but you get a lot as well through
everything I I still have that
connection with my wife and my kids you
know I come home they're excited to see
me and they look at me and
you know I really feel like they know
that I see them
you know and and I'd say that if you're
trying to change anything like the thing
that you should always be most proud of
is that the people that you care about
they know how much you care
I think I sense some emotion coming up
as you talk about that it must mean a
lot to you to know that your family
knows you see them
what piece of advice or wisdom would you
want to make sure you instill in them
it's this idea that when you connect
with people like you can change the
world we often talk about about systems
and you know processes I mean we're
we're a hyper operationalized Society I
think the average Canadian sometimes
looks at leadership in medicine as very
disconnected with with what they're
going through
and it is true in a lot of ways that
when you come into the system you feel
faceless but at the end of the day it
really comes down to people
and connecting with people because I
think if you see each other
clearly and you start to care about each
other again you can't help but change